I'm gonna talk to you about the last few
years that I've spent really
understanding the strategies that
low-resource job seekers use when
they're searching for jobs I'm gonna
talk to you about the barriers that they
face the tools they use in our efforts
to design digital tools to support their
employability
so before I start off I just want to
define what I mean by low resource by
low resource we're pretty much
recruiting from areas that are low
socioeconomic status so low income low
education and most of our job seekers
have limited understanding in terms of
digital access or the digital literacy
is low so first motivate this work by
explaining to you what I mean by
employability so employability is one's
capacity to gain and maintain employment
and it's a key contributor to one's
career success in concert these three
dimensions social and human capital
career identity and personal
adaptability combined to give us rise
and value to employability and each of
these dimensions has their own value and
I'll discuss each next so social capital
refers to those benefits that are
inherent in our own social networks you
guys are here at Stanford you have
access to they're just awesome
connections and some of you may have
chosen to attend because of the social
capital you're able to gain at this
University
human capital is often defined as the
acquisition of useful skills and
knowledge so some of you may be here for
that reason too as you guys just have an
amazing program
so these skills and knowledge they can
be used to create economic value for you
for your employers also for your
community and education and experience
have been found to be the strongest
predictors of career progression so when
we talk about career identity we're
thinking you want to think about the
career experiences and aspirations to
address the question of Who am I so when
you're growing up some people may have
said what do you want to you know what
do you want to do but here we're really
asking who do you want to be this is a
longitudinal thing this is a long-term
process
and so you can express career identity
in the form of stories or narratives and
it requires making sense of your past
and present and giving direction to your
future
so where is career identity asks the
question of who am i or who do I want to
be personal adaptability provides the
how to make it happen so personal
adaptability allows one to adapt to the
changing demands of the work environment
and individuals who embody personal
adaptability have a high propensity to
learn and are open to changing
environments so take for example these
massive open online course learners or
perhaps some of you who may be working
you know full-time going back to school
part-time you guys are you know have
have high your high and your personal
adaptability
so in essence employability is maximized
when there's strength in all three of
these dimensions and my research
investigates how technology supports
employability particularly among low
resource job seekers so I've been
investigated opportunities for new and
existing digital employment tools
real-time ridesharing systems massive
open online courses and one of my
current students have been looking at
people nearby application so these are
applications like Foursquare you can
even think about tinder and he's been
investigating how people are
transitioning to to new careers and how
they are they actually leveraging these
sites for contacts work for employment
so today I'll specifically talk about
how digital employment tools do don't
and could support the employability
construct so the ubiquity of disruptive
technologies such as robotics artificial
intelligence the Internet of Things
really have changed the nature of work
and continues to do so maintaining
employability is crucial however there
are a vast number of tools and
technologies that are already providing
us this type of support for example
there are sites like LinkedIn Coursera
Udacity Amazon Mechanical Turk and up
work these sites provide access to human
and social capital by providing
educational support and access to
professional networks career
identity by exposing job seekers to new
fields and also personal adaptability by
allowing job seekers to work and
experience new fields so a 2015 Pew
report found that 34 percent of recent
job seekers say that online resources
were the most important source of
support in their most recent job search
this is more than connections with close
friends or family however those with
limited socio-economic resources are
less likely to benefit from these
digital resources so this figure shows
the proportion of recent job seekers who
stated that they were not confident in
their ability to perform these six job
search related tasks online and you can
see that there is an extreme spike for
those who haven't attended college so
examples of some of these job search
tasks include contacting potential
employers through email and filling out
job applications so while the Internet
is valuable to job search it's still not
clear how low-resource job lowly low
resource populations are actually
benefiting from it so the nature of work
has changed and it's changing and we see
a number of tools that are available to
support employability for workers
however we must ensure that low resource
job seekers are not being left behind
and this is one of the key motivations
for my research so my team and I have
investigated how digital tools and
technologies could lead to employment
particularly among low resource job
seekers are those with limited education
digital skills or income and so I framed
my presentation around addressing the
following four research questions first
what are the barriers and strategies for
getting ahead and in what ways do and
can employment tools already support
these job seekers what are the
perspectives of external stakeholders
such as career counselors and business
managers and finally how can employment
tools be improved to support all
stakeholders so our research has been
conducted in southeastern Michigan
primarily in Detroit and the demographic
of our job seekers are representative of
the Detroit area which is shown here so
we have about 78
seventy seventy eight point seven
percent black ten point two percent
white and 7% Hispanic the poverty rate
is thirty five point seven percent the
median household is less than $30,000
and in terms of education seventy nine
percent of the population hold a high
school degree or higher but only
thirteen point eight percent hold a
bachelor's degree or higher so
Michigan's traditional unemployment rate
is about four point seven percent so
this was calculated in the third quarter
of 2016 and the second quarter of 2017
but this number would actually increase
to nine point five percent if it
included marginally attached discouraged
or part-time workers and so we refer to
job seekers who have been looking for a
job in the last six months as opposed to
the last month which is calculated in
the traditional unemployment number we
also focused on those job seekers who
had a median income of less than 35 K
and who had less than a four-year degree
so we've used a wide number of
recruiting techniques across our various
studies we've purchased addresses based
on zip codes and we've advertised our
studies through snail mail we've
recruited through our community partners
and organizations and we've also posted
fliers in local community shops like
grocery stores hair salons and
barbershops bus stops as well as
laundromats and then finally we recruit
through Craigslist so I'll present
several studies today that consist of
user centered design approaches such as
interviews and surveys but also design
sessions needs validation and
speed-dating studies and we've also
conducted a pilot deployment and
evaluation so the vast majority of the
research has focused on the perspective
of job seekers as you see here and then
we've we've started recent work asking
the question asking similar questions
with our external stakeholders so that
we can get a more comprehensive view so
we first started out by asking the
research question what are the
strategies and barriers the strategies
people use to get ahead and what are
some of the barriers that they face in
doing so we conducted in
in the summer of 2013 to answer this
question so we conducted a mixed-methods
study consisting of in-depth interviews
participant surveys and a design
scenario exercise we had a total of 36
participants across all these sessions
we first conducted 25 interviews and the
goal of the interviews again was to
understand the strategies that people
use to get ahead in the barriers to
doing so and we then gave each interview
vewy a 20 to 30 minute survey which
really was a community and Technology
Assessment survey we wanted to
understand what types of devices people
had access to so I analyzed the
interview results to derive five
specific scenarios that were
representative of the types of barriers
our jobseekers faced I also captured
aspects of social capital and the
resources these populations access to
get ahead for example people went to
libraries and also public assistant
programs for resources so we also held a
scenario based design session to
understand how groups use their social
capital and they use their resources to
work through these barriers and we again
we captured the these barriers through a
scenario which I present here so you can
imagine that we have five different
scenarios and these scenarios again
tried to capture these this isn't a real
scenario but it is capturing all of the
barriers in the strategies that our
participants faced so and here in in
this scenario we have Sharon who desires
to get an education by for all of our
participants said you know strategy to
getting ahead was to go to school so
Sharon wants to get an education she
took out a loan for her mom which her
mother never paid back so now she's
facing financial difficulties and when
she can't secure a loan for school and
so now she's a bit uncertain about her
future
she really wants to go back to school
but she's not sure if or how she could
pursue a degree if she should pursue an
associate's degree a bachelor's degree
and because she's uncertain about these
things she really doubts her ability to
get ahead so in this scenario session
you know we
these we had five scenarios and we had
four groups there was one group who went
through two scenarios so we had four
groups in the study we gave each group a
digital recorder and we recorded all
conversations and had all sessions
transcribed we designated roles for each
group member in our scenario session and
we did this because we wanted to include
all participants we wanted every
everyone to be engaged so here we had a
resource a designated resource person
this person was responsible for
capturing internal and external
resources used we had a troubleshooter
who was charged with identifying
potential barriers to reaching solutions
to these problems and then finally we
had a scribe who was responsible for
noting answers to preset questions and
reporting out to the team
so the scribe was the person who kept
things going in the session some
questions that the scribe had to make
sure were answered in the session
included where should Sharon go to look
for these resources who should she talk
to who does she contact to learn about
these opportunities and to highlight
some of our findings we saw that
strategies to get ahead included getting
an education this came from our surveys
our interviews and surveys as well as I
scenario sessions our scenario design
sessions provided us with examples of
how participants felt the need to access
support for such resources outside of
the city so many people you know knew
that they had to access resources they
knew that they needed an education but
the question of where would these
resources come from came out and many
people said well they're not here in
Detroit we have to go outside the city
for it for accents so I have here the
notion of social capital even though
people didn't say social capital they
just said that they needed connections
to to others in order to understand how
to how to get ahead so here we had
participants call out the fact that you
can't just go out and get any connection
connections differ so it's critical to
have the right connections and so having
the right connections was a way to get
ahead and not having them was seen as a
barrier so one of our participants
described
getting the hook-up how many of you guys
are familiar with getting a hookup do
you know what that means you get hooked
up you go to I don't know you go to a
supermarket if someone gives you a
discount because they know you're a
Stanford graduate that's getting the
hook-up so some people talked about
getting this hookup and they said if
you're real cool with your counselor
they'll send you an email letting you
know when the funding is coming back
others talked about getting the right
information so this participant said
that people will tell you these things
you have to have to know or you have to
have a worker that's that good that
she's going to tell you so people in a
way talked about this is you know you
you need to be lucky you have to have to
be lucky in order to understand which
resources are here so it wasn't seen as
networking people didn't intentionally
network these were things that happen
you know because they were they're
serendipitous they happen because they
got lucky so in terms of challenges and
barriers to getting ahead neighborhood
transiency led to neighborhood
instability and thus community distrust
so this was the case in both our
interviews and our surveys there are
also challenges regarding poor school
and college preparation and some felt
that limited work was available and also
that having a police record post
challenges but I think the key takeaway
here is the importance of social capital
as a strategy and a barrier to getting
ahead
so overall employment barriers included
limited access
this included limited access to social
and human capital job search feedback
and transportation transportation was a
significant barrier to getting ahead
often leading to individuals not making
it to interviews job fairs or to Career
Services centers success strategies
included networking and mentorship to
navigate those resources that were
available as well as to obtain education
and training for chopped for jobs as a
parent in our scenario with Sharon our
participants lacked career identity and
personal adaptability but they were all
aware of the benefits of social and
human capital so the key takeaway here
is that social capital is incredibly
important when you have strong social
networks the connections can lead to
transportation to work job search
feedback
and information about where to find
inexpensive training so to stress this
point even more I'd like to give you an
example from a recent interview
conducted by one of my PhD students so
in a semi-structured interview with low
resource job seekers my student found
that even job seekers with major
barriers succeed with social support so
Luke was a landscaper with his boss but
for much of the year the landscaping
business didn't have steady business
again I'm coming from Michigan where you
know it's cold half of the year so if
you're in landscaping you may not have a
steady job so Luke says I met my new
employer through my boss he's my boss's
best friend when we had downtime on our
company my boss refers me to whoever
like I said I'd do everything everybody
tries to keep me busy because I've been
homeless I'm still kind of homeless Luke
had a variety of barriers Luke was
epileptic he was a prior felon and semi
homeless yet he was still able to
consistently find work through social
connections so to begin to answer the
second question in what ways do and can
employment tools address these barriers
we use methods inspired by participatory
design so we conducted a three step
design activity with 20 individuals we
gave participant surveys at the start of
our workshop to understand you know what
they knew about the sharing economy
because we thought this could be a
solution to some of the problems and
then we held a design a learning and a
design activity so the workshop lasts
about three hours and each participant
was compensated thirty dollars at a time
so the goal of this session was to
answer two questions are sharing economy
applications feasible for our target
population and could sharing economy
meet the employment needs of our target
population we explicitly asked our
participants to design a system to meet
their employment needs if the sharing
economy applications that we presented
didn't address them so we presented four
applications these were lyft Airbnb
TaskRabbit and neighborhoods because
these tools were available or at least
some one available in the Detroit area
and I encourage you to read the paper
for
but we found that there was some promise
for the sharing economy in these
populations we saw that there was there
was general trust between strangers
idling capacity which mean that you know
people had items to trade or to borrow
and there was overall belief in the
Commons people felt that sharing economy
applications could actually be
supportive in their community
however there needs to be critical mass
as well as the facilitation of safe
financial transactions and clear
transparency around these around how
these systems work particularly around
how ranking and rating works so our
participants didn't really understand
those systems so recall that we
explicitly asked our jobseekers if you
could talk to developers of certain
applications of the sharing economy what
would you tell them to design build
create for you based on your current
situation and so one of our participant
said an app that can kind of do pre
testing and that can help you with your
confidence level your skill level
interviewing process something
job-related like writing and preparing
resumes most commonly asked questions
and how to interview so we took the
barriers in the potential solutions from
our formative work to create a set of
design concepts which we tested among
low resource jobseekers and so to
generate these concepts we also drew
from HCI literature to understand what
tools had already been developed and to
understand whether there were additional
hardships among job seekers upon
generating these concepts we conducted a
speed-dating study to assess and rank
the value of ten different digital tools
so our goal was to get a sense of you
know how how our job seekers prioritize
these tools now the speed-dating study
the way we presented it was somewhat of
an it like an interview process we had a
list of ten different tools that we
showed individuals and basically asked
them to go through the scenarios which
I'll show to you next and rank them and
talk to us about their rankings why did
they rank them in that way so after
reviewing the literature we identified
job search job seeker barriers such as
low wages and homelessness
and from this review we categorized the
challenges as personal challenges social
challenges and societal challenges our
literature review highlighted additional
barriers such as career identity among
homeless populations and also job
availability by Hindry and others
Hindry and our own password reinforced
the need for social connections and also
linden barosky's research highlighted
the need for societal level issues such
as support for wage theft and employee
rights so the lack of transportation
infrastructure was also found and and we
classified that as a societal issue so
just to give you a quick overview of
some of the tools that we developed for
personal we included a concept that we
call skills identifiers skills
identifier is a tool that helps job
seekers identify and communicate their
skills so our story storyboards look
like this and included simple scenarios
that represented pass HCI literature in
our own pass work so in this scenario
Andy wants to work in a customer service
related job he's currently in
construction but he was injured in the
construction you know he was injured on
the job and he's looking for different
types of work he learns about skills
identifier and he enters and he enters
in the system that he's a construction
worker
who wants to go into customer service so
skills identifier shows Joe the common
skills between construction work and
customer service for example he finds
that problem-solving and teamwork skills
are common and this allows him to
highlight these skills in his resume so
that he can go on and become a customer
service rep so we also included a
concept called review me a tool that
enabled job seekers to receive resume
feedback note that this tool was
classified as both personal and social
because it essentially connected job
seekers to volunteers who could review
their resumes finally we included tools
that address societal issues such as the
lack of transportation I won't go into
detail here but due to time but do refer
to our paper for seven more digital
concepts and how they ranked the key
takeaway from this work
was that jobseekers preferred those
tools that address their personal and
most immediate needs for example
everyone needed support in terms of
getting feedback on their resumes or
creating their resumes
there was also job C there are also job
seekers who were looking for volunteer
and community work and needed resources
to address issues such as gaps in their
resumes interestingly the social
applications were wearing were ranked
among the lowest because job seekers
were aware that they didn't have many
people that could vouch for them the
top-rated concept from this study was an
application that we called review me and
this heavily drew from the results of
our earlier studies so review me is a
tool for job seekers and volunteers it
allows job seekers to upload their
resumes and receive feedback from these
volunteers so in this study I'll talk to
you about how we created this tool based
on our formative work and what happened
so you can imagine in this tool that
users log in they can log in as either a
job seeker or volunteer and you can
choose to either seek resume feedback or
provide resume feedback the purpose of
the tool again was to address the
feedback the lack of feedback that we
saw from our formative work but this
tool also served as a conduit to
networks or people who could provide job
seekers with employment feedback so
going back to our employability
framework the tool we described really
supports social capital the tool in a
way is serving as a conduit between
individuals and their social networks
and we wanted to understand the
strengths and limitations of this tool
and under what factors these limitations
exist we wanted to identify a set of UX
design principles that best support at
these strengths and limitations so what
did we do we followed a user centered
design process that consisted of
conducting background research to
understand the additional stakeholders
who were involved in this process
we also talked to job seekers and like
you saw in our past studies we talked to
job seekers but then we found human
resource professionals and trainers who
worked with low resource job seekers and
also ex-felons we conducted survey
contextual inquiries within an earlier
version of our application so we had a
early prototype and then interviews with
our target job seekers we talked to an
HR specialist who had experience working
with these job seekers to get their
feedback
finally we implemented the prototype and
made several iterations over the concept
based on the results of our initial
investigations we deployed our
application and I'll provide the results
of the deployment later finally we
observe the use of our application
through logs but also in person and
reached out to those who had used a tool
after four months for an initial
evaluation so to evaluate our pilot we
send an email to over 300 students
inviting them to participate as
volunteers and also job seekers and we
also purchased LinkedIn and Facebook Ads
we then recruited offline from local
career centers and public libraries so
what do we find here the feedback from
students was overwhelmingly positive the
students loved the resume feedback they
thought it was honest as opposed to
getting feedback from your friends your
friends want to make him feel better
they liked the feedback from the tool
they also preferred expert reviewers
those students really could engage if
the feedback was coming from an expert
or not the thing that the students
didn't like was that there was wait time
depending on which discipline they came
from so there were some resumes that
remained unreviewed now how does this
compare to our target jobseekers this is
really interesting because what we
learned through going out in the real
world and exploring this was that there
was limited access and limited digital
literacy literacy so most of our
jobseekers commented that they didn't
have access to digital resumes many job
seekers from our target population saved
their resumes on public computers and
eventually lost them due to system
upgrades others stored their resumes on
USB flash drives but these devices had
been lost or stolen some individuals had
physical copies of their resumes at
our registration process required users
to confirm their email addresses and we
saw that job seekers search for their
email addresses and upon finding them
they couldn't remember their passwords
so many used the text best the
text-based password retrieval to log
into their accounts
finally our application only accepted
PDFs and one participant didn't
understand how to convert his word
document to a PDF file so we had to walk
them through this process in some cases
we also help job seekers create resumes
because they had lost them so we we did
a lot of hand-holding so I think what's
most alarming about these findings is
that is that these same population
segments are likely unable to submit
basic employment applications or
unemployment applications to or file for
unemployment without significant
hand-holding these populations likely
face other barriers such as signing up
for healthcare or conducting searches
for inexpensive housing so we consider
and we contributed the following design
principles as a start to address some of
the issues we encountered in our
deployment compatibility practicality
direct support and familiarity and
accessibility compatibility many job
seekers didn't have digital copies of
their resumes though several had
physical copies for compatibility we
proposed allowing job seekers to upload
a photograph image of their resume as
smartphones with cameras were pervasive
among our jobseekers practicality some
job seekers had a limited understanding
of how to keep track of digital files
job seekers kept digital copies of their
resumes on thumb drives but these
devices were either lost or so or stolen
so we proposed ways to accept resumes
offline through a kiosk of some sort and
we proposed that these kiosks be
available in accessible locations
because again transportation is an issue
direct support some patrons required
hand-holding so we we suggest built-in
chat support with experts and we're
currently seeing these in the tool
that some of these job seekers are using
finally familiarity and accessibility
though we followed a standard interface
for user registration individuals forgot
passwords to accounts such as email and
we suggest allowing participants to
register with familiar accounts such as
Facebook and Instagram but also SMS
verification or with 2-step verification
phone prompts overall again the tool
worked great for our students but fail
miserably among our low resource job
seekers primarily due to a low digital
literacy overall low digital literacy is
a significant barrier to employment for
our target job our targeted job users
and these seeking these job seekers will
continue to be left behind without
substantial change so in this work we
contributed review me which is a digital
employment tool inspired by
participatory and user centered design
techniques the tool aims to address the
social network gaps that exist in the
employment process and particularly
among these population so we extend past
employment research to aims to address
employment needs among low resource job
seekers the system currently has
limitations we had to recruit volunteers
who provided feedback free of charge
which is not sustainable over the long
term so going forward we plan to
automate resume feedback using Amazon's
Mechanical Turk we plan to adhere to our
own design principles and we want to aim
for a wider scale deployment across
career centers we are also exploring
other types of feedback tools such as
interview feedback so in the next set of
studies we wanted to get kind of a
comprehensive perspective of the job
process so we're trying to understand
from career counselors and business
managers what challenges that do they
see that job seekers face so we
conducted 23 interviews so far with
career advisors business service
coordinators and one employer so career
visors are those who help job seekers
find employment business service
representatives are those who work
directly with the company recruiters and
they also work with human resources
employers are caught of course those
hire our jobseekers so our initial
results reveal that transportation
remains an open challenge and our law
and our yes so transportation remains an
open challenge but we see the
opportunities exist for digital
employment tools to support human
capital career identity and personal
adaptability social capital was not
salient among our external stakeholders
and we think this is because that they
actually serve as social capital so they
wouldn't necessarily see that as a
barrier unfortunately we don't have
enough data from employers to put
together a complete picture but this is
this is work that continues to go on so
in the next slides I'll provide quotes
from our stakeholders to demonstrate
some of our findings so over half of our
career advisors and business service
reps talked about the importance of
having soft skills in the current job
market employers were actually willing
to Train job seekers on how to do the
hard skills as one career advisor stated
I think the number one thing is learning
how to articulate the skills that they
the job seekers have and to match those
soft skills to relatable words is one of
the biggest struggles that we have
because if you can do that you can write
your resume you can write your cover
letter and that leads into everything
else which corresponds to our prior
findings as well so in some cases we saw
that job seekers weren't able to write
their resumes so this was a challenge
recall that job seekers spoke broadly
about the need for education and
training but not soft skills
specifically as a reminder career
identity relates to one's experiences
and aspirations and it addresses the
question of who am i or who do I want to
be career identity could be expressed in
the form of stories or narratives and
one career advisor explained that there
aren't tools available to support this
dimensions of this dimension of
employability he says I don't try to
come up with job titles for them it's
really based on what they say we don't
have the tools for us to sit down and
say oh you sound like you you would be a
marketing engine
or whatever that kind of goes a little
beyond our scope another career visor
stressed the longitudinal nature of
career identity
he said long-term employment comes from
not only meeting your basic needs but
also feeling fulfilled and what you do
so really getting to know someone helps
to figure out what opportunities would
be best for them what's interesting is
that career identity was not a barrier
or strategy identified by our job
seekers so personal adaptability allows
one to adapt to the changing demands of
work environment in the job market
this was another dimension that was
salient among career advisors but hadn't
been mentioned previously by job seekers
so here the career advisor calls out how
job seekers aren't quite sure how or
what steps they need to reach their
career identity he says because
everybody get caught up I want to be a
nurse I want to be a doctor I want to be
this I want to be that but then when you
ask them but where do you see yourself
five years from now I don't know so now
that we've heard the perspectives of
external stakeholders I'd like I like to
compare these perspectives to job
seekers so first and foremost in terms
of challenges limited access to
transportation is a severe barrier for
our job seekers load digital literacy is
also a significant barrier that we
identified in our deployment we also
found in my PhD students study that
digital tools such as indeed were
excellent for finding jobs but not
necessarily for landing them so what we
did find from my students study was that
social capital was key despite the
barriers that jobseekers faced and for
external stakeholders transportation
again showed up as a key barrier and
social capital and low digital literacy
was a challenge among job seekers but
this wasn't mentioned among our external
stakeholders in terms of keys to success
again job seekers saw social capital
both jobseekers and external
stakeholders mentioned human capital
though job seekers were more set on the
hard skills and external stakeholders
felt that soft skills were the key
finally personal adaptability wasn't
mentioned from the perspective of job
seekers though this was a success factor
among our external stakeholders so we
see this as an opportunity to support
both parties so the last step in our
work has been to understand how
employment tools can be improved to
support all stakeholders and we aim to
do this with the tool that we are
calling dream gigs so dream gigs is a
tool that helps job seekers understand
what career related skills they'll need
to reach their ideal or their dream gig
or their dream job our goal for dream
gigs is to support all dimensions of
employability and I'll discuss how after
providing a walkthrough of the tool so
this tool allows users to provide their
current or their most recent job let's
say construction laborers users then
enter their dream job or the job that
they would like to obtain let's say
accountant finally participants can
enter their geographic location let's
say Detroit so this step requires one to
consider who do you want to be
we then tap into the data at work API
which I can discuss later if there's
time but the API allows us to take the
skills that you would have as a
construction laborer and then take the
skills that you would need as an
accountant and we we take the difference
like what is it that you actually need
in order to become an accountant that
you don't have so once we have that we
present the users with the skills that
they need to acquire in order to reach
their dream job so here users select
economics and accounting and
mathematical reason reasoning because
this step requires provides the skills
need needed to reach the selected dream
dream job we characterize this step as
human capital we then take these skills
economics and accounting and input each
back into the data at work API this
provides us with a list of jobs that job
seekers could do in order to obtain
these skills this is what you see here
so you can think about
as the skills acquisition stuff so users
can see a list of related jobs that they
could do and we also allow users to
select one of these related occupations
to see what jobs actually exists in
their area so for example if someone
could select correspondent clerks recall
that personal adaptability allows one to
adapt to the changing demands of the
work environment in the job market this
list of related jobs shows job seekers
which jobs that they could consider to
reach their dream job finally after
selecting one of the related jobs users
are able to see if this job or related
jobs are available in their area here
we're pulling available jobs through
indeed but we've also considered pulling
jobs from Craigslist because those are
more gig like we've also considered
pulling skills or classes that are
available through MOOCs but I'll tell
you later why we're not doing that right
now
so for job seekers we've been
prioritizing opportunities to bring them
face to face with other individuals to
build social and human capital so we've
decided not at this point to pull in
courses from massive open online for to
pull in MOOCs or to pull in YouTube
videos that can help with these skills
we you know as a side thing we're
looking at ways that people could learn
as a group again our research is telling
us that social capital is really
important so we don't really want our
jobseekers to work in isolation we're
also looking at volunteer opportunities
actually this is what you see here so
they can not only get the the jobs from
indeed but they can seek volunteer
opportunities now some of you may be
wondering you know hey Towanda you just
mentioned that digital literacy is a
significant barrier
why are you proposing this tool well
first there wasn't a login screen
there's nothing that needs to be
uploaded so jobseekers can really use
this as a fully informational tool so
our goal also was to make this an
inclusive tool so we're not
we're not just you know designing for a
mobile phone we're designing for desktop
applications as well and what we're
really advocating for this tool is not
just designing for the job seeker but
we're advocating that we design for
intermediaries as well so we think that
we could bring in job seekers who may
have you know some level of digital
literacy as well as job seekers
who you know may need support from the
intermediaries we believe that the
intermediaries can bridge the gaps that
we're seeing in digital literacy we also
know from our interviews with with these
external stakeholders the career
counselors that they're able to connect
job seekers to resources such as mentors
transportation also education we also
know from our external stakeholders that
they could provide referrals so to
summarize our findings and conclude the
talk we find that job seekers barriers
and strategies barriers to getting ahead
in strategies to getting ahead include
accessing social resources getting
feedback on their job search education
and training and also transportation we
saw how employment tools can address
these barriers but that digital literacy
was a barrier so we contributed these
four design principles for designers to
adhere to compatibility practicality
direct support and familiarity and
accessibility we also raised a question
of external stakeholder perspectives we
found here that career advisors and
business services representatives their
key challenges and strategies for
success included building human capital
particularly soft skills translating
skills for career identity and getting
jobseekers to consider long-term
employment and not just a short-term
which is related to one's personal
adaptability finally as an example of
how employment tools can be improved to
support all stakeholders we propose
building tools like dream gigs tools
that support social and human capital
career identity and personal
adaptability or all dimensions of
employability
say that while social capital and access
to social networks by far is a key
challenge for our jobseekers
transportation is a serious barrier I
just want to call out that we did
investigate this further in fact this
barrier drove our investigation into
ways in which transportation could
broadly support employment actually
getting the work to job interviews to
career counselors so in a study that we
conducted we are boarded individuals to
Auburn and we did face challenges such
as digital literacy which I encourage
you to read the paper
but for those individuals who were able
to be on boarded we were able to do so
successfully from the support of our
intermediaries such as job training
centers and community organizations so
after working through the challenges we
found that real-time ridesharing systems
are an excellent solution for low
resource job seekers but we do need to
minute lower the cost of such services
because you know that is a barrier but
once we get through that we think it
could be a solution in fact in a
follow-on study to this what we found
was that passengers the the passengers
in the uber ride actually received
emotional support from their drivers
they were told to not give up the job
search they were told about local jobs
that were available so we saw this as an
opportunity for people to build social
capital or to develop social capital so
the key takeaways in the talk are that
social capital is vital we need to
leverage technology to engage low
resource job seekers with available
social resources offline connecting to
intermediaries may actually be key in
addressing issues of digital literacy
and an employability is a long-term not
a one-time endeavor so with that I'd
like to thank you for your time I'd like
to thank my research team and
collaborators and I also like to thank
our funders NSF University of Michigan's
Ford's School of Public Policy and also
U of M's poverty solutions and I'll take
your questions
[Applause]